so if you see my video on Deadpool
explain you'll know that he first
appeared in Marvel Comics with New
Mutants issue number 98 and was created
as a clone of DC's Deathstroke however
in that video we had actually skimmed
over Liefeld's work and instead focus
heavily on the writings of Joe Kelly
Christopher priest and Gail Simone and
so what I want to do here is take a step
back and focus on the original Deadpool
as he was created by Rob Liefeld as well
as his involvement and the tail end of
the New Mutants line going into the
launch of x-force and his initial
conflict with cable
so throughout the 1990s the comic-book
industry was largely at the height of
its popularity if we don't take into
account the present-day during this time
publishers like DC marvel valiant Dark
Horse Fleetway and Harvey were all
releasing comics in an effort to either
maintain their position in the industry
or carve out a position for themselves
among the established competitors to
this end it was not uncommon to see
characters introduced without
backstories the reason for this was that
the industry was moving a mile a minute
and while mainstays like Batman's
Superman spider-man and the x-men were
heavyweights at the time publishers were
continuing to look for ways to expand
the industry as a whole as a result and
within marvel story arcs were written
and ended involving major characters or
teams but saw the introduction of heroes
like GW bridge Bishop gambit and cable
in an effort to test fan and reception
meaning that if readers enjoy these
characters Marvel would expand on the
roles if not Marvel simply killed them
off or wrote them out of the story never
to be seen or heard from again at the
same time and following its creation in
1982 by writer Chris Claremont and
artist Bob McLeod the New Mutants line
proved to be wildly popular in that it
focused on a young team of mutants with
relatively exotic powers coming together
under the tutelage of Charles Xavier
designed to be a throwback to the
original x-men comics of the 1960s
because Claremont was considered the
definitive x-men writer almost
everything he touched at the time that
involved mutants was considered cold and
readers flocked by the droves to grab
the series while new mutants did slump
for time and that it wasn't quite out of
the game but it was certainly being
handed a tap the title was handed over
to Rob Liefeld in 1989 who we
invigorated a line by removing the
characters from the leadership of
Charles Xavier
and placing them under the guidance of
the newly created cable planning to
cancel out the new mutants series with
issue number 100 and relaunch at under
the title of x-force with new memes
issue number 98 Rob Liefeld and Fabien
de Caesar initiated a three-part story
titled the beginning of the end running
to issue number 100 that fulfilled this
purpose but also saw the introductions
of Deadpool and Vanessa Carlysle having
said that I want to shift our focus to
shining some light on cable and clearing
up some of the confusion that may exist
out there for new readers as a character
that originally appeared an uncanny
x-men issue number 201 in 1986
cable is the son of Scott Summers and
matt'll
prior the clone of Jean Grae at the time
of his creation mr. sinister was still a
large part of the Marvel continuity and
at Harvard a vendetta against apocalypse
for bestowing sinister with immortality
to this end because of his experience in
studying the genes of mutants sinister
came to the realization that the genetic
offspring a Cyclops and Jean would
produce a wildly powerful mutant that
would easily be able to topple
apocalypse however because Jean was
believed to have died following the
events of the original Phoenix saga
sinister created a clown named adalynn
prior which served the purpose of
entering Scott Summers life seducing him
and producing a child where the
intention of sinister was to allow the
child to grow naturally only intervening
when its powers manifested apocalypse
became aware of senator's plan and
kidnapped cable as an infant exposing
him to the techno-organic virus a
disease which converts living tissue to
something akin to machinery the x-men
and the Inhumans intervened saving
cables life but not before half of his
body was exposed and so taking him
several thousand years into the future
in the hopes of finding a cure following
Jean Grey's return her spiritual essence
alongside Scott's were taken to the
future as well to raise cable while this
time was ruled by apocalypse and no cure
was available as his telepathic and
telekinetic powers began to manifest
cable began to use them subconsciously
in an effort to keep the techno-organic
buyers from eating his body alive
furthermore because he grew up in an age
when apocalypse had ruled the world
Kable developed a hatred for the villain
and his cruel ways leading him to travel
into the past on several occasions in an
attempt to destroy apocalypse having
said that while the New Mutants team did
leave Charles Xavier and come under the
leadership of cable at the time of this
story as the son of Madeline prior in
Scott Summers from the future he was
essentially brought up with the
teachings of the x-men and carried on
the legacy of focusing heavily on
training in order to hone the skills of
the new mutants
however because cable hails from a
future where apocalypse had taken over
the world the harsh nature of his life
at the time prior to traveling into the
past became an ingrained part of his
personality bidding to him focusing on a
more intense method of training in an
effort to ensure that the mutant
community was able to hold off the
various campaigns of apocalypse and
prevent the future from happening
now with that being said the first
appearance of Deadpool came without too
much explanation by Rob Liefeld the
reason for this was that during the
1990s comic book stories were written in
a way that would keep readers coming
back by teasing important information
that wouldn't be covered until later in
the story arc in this instance
Liefeld simply tells us that deadpool
had been hired by someone named mr.
Toliver and the Toliver blames cable for
an event that happened in the past
although we don't know what it is
something that I also hope you notice
here is that Deadpool is absolutely
nothing like the version that we know
today the reason for this is actually
twofold
the first is it like cable Liefeld was
testing the waters with Deadpool to see
if fans were interested in seeing a
character that could function as a
returning villain to challenge cable
time and time again the second is that
Deadpool was a reflection of comics in
the 1990s to sidetrack here for those of
you who have seen my videos on this
particular topic bear with me for a
second while I run over this for those
who haven't so while the 1960s 70s and
80s saw the introduction and
establishment of most of the characters
that we know today the 1990s as a whole
was an explosive time in human history
concentrating on the advancement of
technology in the early formations of
the digital age but also saw an expanse
on the cultural invasion of Asian
animation professional wrestling and
live Asian TV shows like Power Rangers
all of which came together to create a
veritable witches brew a fast-paced
high-intensity action indeed comic books
as a whole reflected these themes in
that Jim Lee's artistry during his time
on x-men vol 2 inspired the development
of x-men the animated series a TV show
whose popularity in turn push the comic
book industry to design more characters
to reflect a high intensity futuristic
theme in addition to this stories like
1971 the night Gwen Stacy died in 1986
as the Dark Knight Returns laid the
groundwork for darker stories that
presented scenarios or the hero didn't
always come out on top and sometimes
even died as was the case with the death
and return of Superman conversely
because The Dark Knight Returns took
Batman back to his daugher roots the
story paved the way for 80 heroes like
The Punisher and Deadpool who didn't
ally themselves with right or wrong but
held an allegiance to their own moral
code which may have changed depending on
the writer and the public mood in
relation to comics now regarding Vanessa
Carlysle where new mutants issue number
98 focused on creating popularity for
Deadpool by having him single-handedly
take out
team in cable Carlisle was introduced as
a ruse by Liefeld who use the scenario
to introduce two characters
the first was Domino and the second was
Vanessa Carlysle impersonating Domino
the reason for this was that with the
mobile community aware of what the new
mutants were capable of in that boom
boom could create plasma bombs that
exploded on impact rusty was able to
control fire Richter could create
shockwaves and skids could use force
fields the idea of a mercenary suddenly
appearing and taking them all out was a
bit of a surprise conversely with an
unknown woman an ally of q-ball taking
out Deadpool questions reigned among
readers as to who Deadpool and Domino
were and what was going on to this end
Liefeld anesthesia established a history
between cable and Domino that predated
the story taking place sometime prior to
cables first appearance now to focus on
Deadpool for a second going through this
comic the inspiration for Joe Kelly's
run on his character came in the dark
humor of Wade as he was written by the
season and Liefeld what I mean here is
that where Kelly made Deadpool a little
crazier and even had in reference his
own comics on the whole the sarcastic
nature of Deadpool as he was depicted
here carried itself over into Kelly's
run and that when cable asked the
question of what they should do with him
Deadpool replies by stating that he's
always wanted to rehabilitate himself
somewhere nice like a prison in the
Bahamas now this bit is meant to be both
funny but also established that Deadpool
is a mercenary who's simply doing a job
and doesn't really care about cable at
all and so when the comic would see
cable and Domino dealing with Wade by
sitting him back to Tolliver to report
his failure and killing cable Messina in
Liefeld said about expanding on the plot
further by exposing Vanessa Carlysle as
a spy and personating Domino before
jumping into this though I won a
sidetrack for a second and focus on the
backstory of Vanessa herself so not much
is known about the past of an esse what
in truth her past isn't really relevant
now I don't say this out of spite for
her character I say this because Vanessa
always function in the background of
Marvel Comics in truth the introduction
of copycat only really came as a way for
his season in life held to make the
story of cable ending the New Mutants
and forming the x-force a little more
interesting however because dead will
prove to be so popular going into Joe
Kelly's run efforts were made to expand
on Carlyle after her history was left
unexplained by Liefeld and miss ISA
having said that as far as we're told
and dead full volume one issue number
negative one
somewhere along the line Carlisle became
a woman of the night after her family
had kicked her out of her home for being
a mutant with the ability to shape-shift
now to focus on her powers for a second
the major difference between Vanessa and
other shapeshifters is that instead of
taking on a person's physical appearance
like mystique vanessa copies them down
to the cellular level meaning that she
has the same DNA and she can copy the
powers of others hence the reason why
she took the name copycat but during her
time as a working girl vanessa had met
and fall in love with Wade now in terms
of Deadpool's timeline this particular
bit took place during his time as a
mercenary for hire and prior to
developing cancer and enter the Weapon X
program now from the perspective of
Anessa because she had been cast out of
her family and forced to sell her body
as a mean to take care of herself she
was a quintessential example of someone
suffering from avoidant personality
disorder particularly the self deserting
element of milind subtypes defined by
the characteristics of locking out the
reality of a person's situation
discarding painful images and memories
or else casting away flawed thoughts and
impulses vanessa fits this diagnosis in
the sense that she believes Wade will
take her away from the life that she
leads now while this is true to a degree
in the sense that way does Harbor
somewhat of a love for her following his
diagnosis of cancer in pursuit of the
Weapon X program as a potential cure
vanessa was cast back to her life of a
solitary existence as a prostitute and
so following this we don't really know
what happened to her except to say that
she began using our powers as a means to
become an assassin leading to her
employment by mr. Tolliver however
because this backstory was provided and
Deadpool volume 1 issue number negative
1 in 1997 at the time of both Wei de
Menezes first appearance in New Mutants
issue number 98 in 1991 this history was
unknown with the reader being led to
believe that the Domino that we were
seeing in New Mutants issue number 98
was the true character that said were
the x-force comics leading into issue
number 14 focused largely on
establishing the updated team roster
including warpath and a handful of
others Deadpool did make several
appearances the reason for this was at
at the time
Liefeld anesthesia were taking the time
to add some meat and potatoes by
establishing that Wade was doing more
than just attempting to kill cable while
some of these instances involved taking
down juggernaut
and black Tom Cassidy fan interest in
Deadpool achieved a noticeable jump
during the events of x-force issue
number two centering on a battle between
Wade and garrison Kane a former member
of cables team who is believed to have
died in an explosion
the rise of Deadpool's popularity began
when it was revealed that Kane had
survived the conflict after being
abducted by the Weapon X program and
reconditioned as a villain now the
reason why this bolstered Wade's
popularity was that while this story was
progressing in x-force Marvel was
releasing the model presents series
which focused on Wolverines experience
at Weapon X however the web and X story
was only a couple of issues and leading
to fans wondering whether or not the
reveal of Deadpool having been a former
member of the project meant that he
would essentially be another rule brain
or provide another version of the events
depicted and Marvel presents while this
didn't happen because fans had been
reading heavily into the actions of
Deadpool during his appearances in
x-force if only by association a fan
base started to grow regarding his dark
and sarcastic humor to this end
Deadpool's reimagines with an x-force
regarding the reveal of vanessa acting
as a spy didn't come until issue number
eleven and the revelation the vanessa
had been working for mr. Toliver and was
assigned the task of killing cable
however because Vanessa's time with the
team had satisfied her need to belong
and have some measure of family she
essentially abandoned her mission and
even fell in love with cable as a result
the introduction of Deadpool in a Marvel
comics was routed for the purpose of
finding out what happened to Vanessa and
why she failed her mission at a
sidetrack for a second I want to provide
a bit of a discussion on who mr.
Tolliver is and jeongmi back to cable
during his time in the future and after
growing into an adult cable had married
a woman named Dahlia and produced a son
named Tyler however Tyler was kidnapped
by the villain strife and subjected to
torture and mental reconditioning
eventually be emerging as a villain to
this end because Tyler had put Cable in
a position where he was forced to shoot
his own son while Tyler survived the
encounter he travelled into the past
during cables time as leader of the New
Mutants leading to the current situation
now to be honest here I'm actually sort
of dancing around this topic a bit and
the reason why is that a video will be
forthcoming on strife and so I don't
actually want to spoil the entire basis
behind it but with Deadpool's
reappearance in confrontation with
Vanessa
after a short fight between the two Wei
delivers it also made him for mr.
Toliver essentially telling her to
either continue her mission or
died that said where Vanessa had become
attached to cable and x-force during her
time impersonating Domino because of her
encounter with Deadpool the situation
became clear and that as long as
Tolliver remained alive he would hold
her to the mission of killing cable to
this end she sought to kill Tolliver by
taking cable to his location through a
series of access tunnels under
Tolliver's base of operations however
the situation came to a head when it was
revealed that the tunnels housed the
real Domino who has been held prisoner
allowing Vanessa to take her place
now this particular part of the story is
a quintessential example of what I was
referring to you regarding characters
being written in and killed off for the
sake of moving the plot in a forward
direction what I mean here is that
because Vanessa was introduced for the
purpose of building interest in cable by
creating a series of events that led up
to a final confrontation between cable
and mr. Tolliver Vanessa had essentially
served her purpose and was shelved for
time what I mean here is that where life
failed and it sees a depict Wade
stabbing her in the back
she actually survives the encounter but
the emphasis was never on building her
up as a star instead she was a means to
an end and it wouldn't be until Joe
Kelly's run on Deadpool that Vanessa
would re-emerge from the realm of
obscurity and back into the limelight
having said that the issue that we face
with the battle between Deadpool and
cable is it at the time Rob Liefeld was
on his way out of Marvel following his
formation of Image Comics alongside Todd
McFarlane Jim Lee Marc Silvestri Erik
Lawson and Jim Valentino as a result
writer fabian Aziza was left to clean up
a lot of the concepts leading two
debates among fans regarding how the
events concluded and how they were
supposed to conclude had Liefeld's
stayed on and a creative capacity what I
mean here is that while this is
considered by many to be one of the best
fights in Marvel Comics which is ironic
considering cable and Deadpool would go
on to become friends and allies the
cable statements of intending to go
man-to-man with Deadpool and wanting to
settle the fight one final time seemed
to indicate that the conflict would end
with one of them dying
moreover where cable was able to free
the real Domino after momentarily
subduing Deadpool when Wade had jumped
back into the conflict and attacked
cable a second time
Domino fired a shot in his back stating
that she had killed him following this
with mr. Toliver escaping and allowing
from all to follow up with expansions on
cables history within the pages of
x-force the conclusion of the story also
saw Deadpool survive
the encounter Pescara Vanessa had
escaped which left the door open for
Marvel to expand on their relationship
as well now with all that being said if
you're interested in learning more about
Deadpool's history going from these
initial appearances to the modern day I
have a playlist with around 20 videos
that should answer a majority of your
questions but something to know is that
I will be adding to it over time and so
if you have questions that aren't
answered there feel free to send those
questions to me on Twitter and I'll
answer them as best I can with that
being said we're going to bring this
video to an end and I will catch you
guys on their pace